y
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa soy santiago lópez gonzález este
es el espacio de france 24 en el que
hacemos un recorrido por las noticias
más destacadas a lo largo de las semanas
relacionadas con la pandemia del cob y
19 a continuación los temas que
trataremos en esta emisión
hablaremos con nuestro asesor científico
el doctor pérez sobre las variantes de
kobe 19 que han comenzado a surgir en
diferentes regiones del planeta incluida
nuestra región américa latina en donde
la variante brasileña ya disparó las
alarmas les explicamos cómo surgen estas
variantes y qué significa esto para la
lucha contra la pandemia a nivel global
también daremos un vistazo al avance de
la vacunación en américa latina' varios
países de la región recibieron nuevos
lotes de vacunas para seguir avanzando
en la inmunización bolivia se prepara
para comenzar inoculaciones en los
próximos días mientras que chile recibió
su primer lote de vacunas producidas en
china y también profundizaremos en el
caso de colombia un país que superó ya
los 2 millones de casos de contagio y ya
tiene más de 52 mil personas fallecidas
entre ellos el ministro de defensa de
ese país esto mientras colombia sigue
aguardando impacientemente la llegada de
las vacunas que según lo ha dicho el
gobierno la inmunización a nivel
nacional podría comenzar a partir del 20
de febrero son algunos de los temas hay
muchos más así que
vemos
el hallazgo de nuevas variantes de
covite 19 o de coronavirus en alrededor
de 14 países del continente americano ha
generado preocupación entre las
autoridades y en organismos
internacionales dado que estos podrían
ser más contagiosos o también mortales
en nuestra región una variante
encontrada en brasil y otra en eeuu
anunciada hace pocos días encendió las
alarmas de las autoridades vamos a
analizar el tema con el doctor carlos
eduardo pérez el desinfectó logo de la
universidad nacional de colombia también
es asesor científico de france 24 una
cara conocida aquí en nuestro canal el
doctor pérez gracias por estar con
nosotros como siempre esté resolviendo
nuestras dudas y las de los televidentes
porque ahora casi un año después del
inicio de esta emergencia sanitaria
debido al coronavirus parece que está
comenzando a aparecer un montón de
variantes en diferentes partes del mundo
que lo que sucede en este momento con el
virus en particular
santiago buenas noches una de las cosas
que debemos tener en cuenta es que entre
mayor número de contagios mayor número
de probabilidad que el virus mute
los virus evolucionan las mutaciones
hacen parte de esa evolución es decir
que en la medida que se incrementan el
número de contactos y pasa el tiempo hay
mayor prueba ya que estas mutaciones
conviertan a los virus en algo distinto
que se llaman linajes y eso y linajes
que se convierten pueden ser o más
infectantes o menos infectantes en este
caso algunas de estas variantes son mas
infectantes
doctor porque están apareciendo estas
variantes esto influye de pronto algunas
particularidades del medio ambiente
porque vemos que unas han surgido en
brásil otra ha surgido en sudáfrica que
son países que están en este momento en
la temporada del verano austral pero
también hay una variante que surgió en
el reino unido donde están en pleno
invierno hace unas horas o hace unos
días eeuu también anunció que parece que
ha encontrado una variante en california
no no se relaciona con problemas
ambientales es con la dinámica de la
infección en donde hemos visto es donde
hay una gran explosión de casos mira lo
que en manaos una primera ola y luego
una segunda habla muy importante con
gran número de casos y estas variantes
pueden aparecer lo mismo pasó en
reinounido cada uno de los países cada
una de las regiones va a tener variantes
es algo inevitable es algo que los virus
van a ser siempre van a mutar sino que
algunas de estas variantes son
particularmente efectivas en su
transmisión son las que se monitorizan y
pueden incrementar el número de
contagios doctor qué diferencia a estas
variaciones del virus qué diferencia
tiene la que se ha desarrollado en
sudáfrica con la del reino unido la de
california la de brasil en que las
podemos diferenciar
entonces hemos dicho que las mutaciones
producen linajes y los linajes pueden
aumentar o la efectividad de la
transmisión o la virulencia es decir la
capacidad de enfermar lo que hemos visto
en la mutante del reino unido- y es una
de sudáfrica es que aumentan la
contagiosidad es decir que es mucho más
fácil que una persona al estar cerca se
contagie y algunas como la que pasa en
manaos primero escapan al sistema
inmunológico es decir que no es efectiva
el sistema inmunológico para
controlarlas y además de eso pueden
incrementar su virulencia es decir su
capacidad de enfermar entonces estudia
linaje se monitorizan o son más
impedidos o son más agresivos y por eso
es que digamos tenemos que estar atentos
para poder saber cómo reaccionar en el
momento en que ingresen estos linajes a
los países o que los países empiecen a
producir sus propios linajes y
exportarlos a trocitos doctor pérez lo
que estamos haciendo en este momento es
decir poner en marcha planes de
vacunación con diferentes tipos de
vacuna que tienen diferentes porcentajes
de
efectividad las medidas de bioseguridad
que en la mayoría de los países todavía
se mantienen lavarse las manos usar el
tapabocas los toques de queda los
confinamientos esto puede cercar el
virus de alguna forma y evitar que se
empiecen a desarrollar más variantes de
las que ya tenemos
esa es la estrategia de inmunización y
desaceleración de los casos porque si
los casos se siguen acelerando pueden
haber linajes y la vacuna que se colocó
sería efectiva entonces es en paralelo
se está vacunando es acceder a las casas
con las medidas de confinamiento y se
mantiene toda la bioseguridad hasta qué
momento hasta que entre un 70 y 85 por
ciento de la población está inmunizada y
ya el virus deja el circular ahí
podríamos empezar a controlar la
pandemia realmente en resumen vamos por
buen camino lento pero seguro entonces
doctor según lo que usted está diciendo
quiero que analicemos esta frase doctor
para aclararle a los televidentes porque
esto es una pregunta reiterativa por
parte de los televidentes a través de
las redes sociales más contagio no
significa mayor letalidad
entonces tratamos si hay mayor número de
personas enfermas pues hay más chance
que las personas se compliquen entonces
poder aumentar el número de muertos
ese es el linaje de reino unido por
ejemplo que aumenta la contagiosidad
entonces si van a ver mil enfermos hay
10.000 enfermos entonces y hay 10.000
enfermos pues hay mal chance de que haya
fallecidos en ese número de 10.000
porque aumenta el número de casos pero
hay otras como puede ser la semana 2
otras variantes virales que aumentan es
la agresividad es decir que ya no
solamente en tres sino que enferma más a
la persona entonces sí puede suceder las
dos cosas definitivamente el ingreso en
los linajes aumenta el número de casos o
va a aumentar la mortalidad por el
número de casos o por la capacidad del
virus para infectar por eso
desaceleración las medidas de
bioseguridad y la vacunación masiva que
está lenta bastante lenta pero necesaria
va a poder controlar la pandemia doctor
pérez esta semana también hubo polémica
a través de las redes sociales también
por medio de los medios de comunicación
en diferentes
y sobre todo con el surgimiento de estas
variantes y el debate se centra ahora en
el tapabocas en que el tapabocas de tela
no es tan efectivo como un tapabocas
quirúrgico para hacer frente a estos a
estas variantes del virus que ya usted
explicó algunos son un poco más
agresivos en algunas de sus
características no quiere decir que sea
más letal y eso genera un poco de
preocupación por parte de los ciudadanos
no solamente aquí en américa latina sino
también en europa en donde están
haciendo frente precisamente a la
variante británica
los tapabocas son fundamentales
obviamente entre más eficientes son los
quirúrgicos los que se utilizan en los
hospitales las máscaras los respiradores
los tapabocas convencionales los que
usamos los médicos en los post eventos
son también muy efectivos el problema de
los tapabocas de tela es que hay tapado
cada tela de baja calidad en muy mala
calidad o hay tapabocas que si cumplen
algunas normas que sean telas
quirúrgicas que tengan peligros que
tengan tres capas y podrían ser
efectivos aquí la recomendación es usar
siempre un tapabocas si tiene disponible
una mascarilla quirúrgica póngase la isi
que sea un tapabocas de tela de buena
calidad puede colocarlo y si tiene dedos
para colocarse doble tapabocas de tela
convencional llamémoslo así y lo ayuda a
proteger aquí exponer una barrera física
para evitar que contagie cuál es la
clave que el tapaboca no se retire
porque por ejemplo en el transporte
público la gente lo puede usar mucho
tiempo en transporte público lo retira
pues ahí puede contagiarse entrando un
baño si se quita el tapabocas que es un
ambiente cerrado poco ventilado puede
adquirir el virus es mantener el
tapabocas
que ser como tiene que usarlo todo el
tiempo que esté en contacto con otras
personas o en ambientes no ventilados
doctor tengo tiempo para hacerlo una
última pregunta relacionada con la
vacuna que fue anunciada esta semana que
también tiene un alto porcentaje de
efectividad es una compañía
estadounidense y su vacuna se llama
novavax y tal parece que esta vacuna
funciona distinta a las otras que ya
están autorizadas y que están siendo
inoculadas que sabe usted de los
reportes científicos y médicos en torno
a esta vacuna
esta semana ha sido muy buena en cuanto
a noticias de vacunas como mamás es una
vacuna que es de proteínas ya no es el
rn a mensajeros los haciendo un pleito
sino la proteína en unas nanopartículas
y con efectividad por encima del 85
hasta el 89 por ciento
janssen también liberó los resultados
que muestra que en regiones puede llegar
a 85 a 65 por ciento pero es muy
interesante como después de 30 días se
incrementa la inmunidad y se mantiene en
el tiempo y ya hay más información
acerca de la seguridad de las vacunas de
ácidos nucleicos en donde el riesgo de
infección de reacción alérgica es casi
de una 500 mil millones extremadamente
bajo es una muy buena noticias son muy
buenas nos dice en cuanto a la
inmunización digamos que a la
expectativa establecen la accesibilidad
a la óptica doctor pérez como siempre un
gusto hablar con usted usted nos aclara
este panorama de la situación semana a
semana muchas gracias por estar con
nosotros en france 24 ya ha respondido
estas preguntas y ha aclarado la
situación para nuestros televidentes
muchas gracias
pues veamos entonces cómo está el
panorama general en el continente y cómo
está avanzando la inmunización en los
pocos países de la región que ya tienen
en marcha sus planes de vacunación hasta
el 28 de enero de 2021 veamos cómo van
las cifras eeuu va liderando en el
continente va liderando la vacunación
allí con 26 puntos 19 millones de dosis
aplicadas le sigue brasil en donde han
sido ya aplicadas 1.45 millones de dosis
canadá pese a las demoras que ha tenido
para recibir las vacunas ya a inocular
inoculado 910 mil 676 dosis y se
aproxima ya al millón
méxico- 657 mil 842 dosis también han
sido allí inoculadas en el siguiente
gráfico vemos que en este listado
también está argentina que ya ha
vacunado a 327 mil 999 personas y sigue
recibiendo vacunas procedentes de rusia
su vecino chile cierra esta semana con
67 mil 111 dosis inoculadas costa rica
en centroamérica 48 mil 128
mientras que panamá alcanzó ya las 6 mil
420 dosis ecuador en sudamérica 2 mil
982 dosis han sido aplicadas para el
cierre de esta semana en ese país
suramericano
y ya lo decíamos chile recibió su primer
cargamento de casi 2 millones de dosis
de la vacuna elaborada por la
farmacéutica china sinovac las mismas
hacen parte de este plan de vacunación
nacional impulsado por el gobierno
central y serán inoculadas en adultos
mayores a partir de la próxima semana un
segundo lote procedente de china con
otros 2 millones de dosis adicionales
llegarán al territorio chileno el 31 de
enero y van a ser distribuidas también
en todo el territorio nacional en esta
oportunidad por primera vez va a ser
incluida la isla de pascua que está en
el pacífico y pertenece a chile hasta el
momento ya lo decíamos hay más de 67 mil
dosis aplicadas en esta primera fase de
inmunización en chile
la disponibilidad de la vacuna la
aprobación
el s&p y la decisión del ministro de
salud nos permiten iniciar la próxima
semana probablemente el día miércoles
después de tener los certificados que
acreditan la seguridad de esta vacuna
vamos a poder iniciar en todas las
regiones del país un proceso de
vacunación masiva y bolivia se convirtió
esta semana en el quinto país de américa
del sur en recibir sus primeros lotes de
vacunas sputnik ve para comenzar con un
ambicioso plan de vacunación contra el
cubil 19 esto cuando el gobierno también
reportó que el canciller boliviano
rogelio mayta fue dado de alta tras
permanecer cuatro semanas internado para
ser tratado por haber sido contagiado
con kobe 19 bolivia registra hasta el
momento más de 210 mil casos de contagio
y unas 10.200 personas han perdido la
vida debido al coronarios
más detalles sobre el plan de vacunación
que va a comenzar en bolivia y la
situación en general de ese país vamos a
conversar entonces con mery vaca nuestra
corresponsal permanente en la ciudad de
la paz
hola mary comencemos con los detalles de
la llegada de este primer lote de
vacunas a bolivia que ya entra entonces
en la lista de los países que van
tomando delantera en la inoculación de
sus ciudadanos
hola qué tal santiago así es bolivia ha
iniciado la vacunación de su personal
sanitario que trabaja en la primera
línea combatiendo los casos de
coronavirus y lo ha hecho con un pequeño
lote de vacunas que ha recibido de rusia
se trata de 20 mil dosis de la vacuna
sputnik 5 que van a servir para vacunar
a 10.000 personas pues se necesitan dos
dosis por cada persona a inmunizarse los
médicos y los dirigentes del sector
sanitario han señalado que estas vacunas
no van a alcanzar para todo el personal
sanitario pues en bolivia existen
alrededor de 200.000 salubristas es
decir que se cubriría con este primer
lote sólo al 1% de los trabajadores pero
también hay que comentarles que el
presidente luís arce ha suscrito un
convenio para la adquisición de 5.2
millones de vacunas rusas que van a
llegar próximamente aunque no se tiene
precisión de las fechas hay que decir
también que algunos sectores han
criticado que el gobierno haya elegido a
la vacuna rusa pues
no ha cumplido con todas sus fases de
desarrollo a nivel internacional en
cambio el gobierno ha reaccionado
firmando otro convenio para adquirir
otras 5 millones de vacunas de la
astrazéneca y al margen de eso el
gobierno también espera la llegada de
otras 5 millones de vacunas de la
iniciativa kóvacs a través de la
cooperación internacional con esto
bolivia tendría alrededor de 15 millones
de dosis para inmunizar alrededor de 7.5
millones de habitantes que es la
totalidad de la población vacuna bleu en
bolivia mery pero entonces como van a
ser distribuidas las vacunas de este
primer lote cómo va a avanzar o cómo se
va a poner en marcha este plan de
vacunación
si es muy poco lo que se conoce respecto
al plan de vacunación lo que ha dicho el
gobierno es que este va a correr por
cuenta de los gobiernos regionales lo
que se sabe es que en primera instancia
se va a vacunar obviamente al personal
sanitario luego también se va a vacunar
a las personas de la tercera edad y
aquellas personas que tienen
enfermedades de base para luego pasar a
vacunar al resto de la población
boliviana debo comentarles que en estas
en esta jornada ha habido algunas
polémicas porque un parlamentario del
movimiento al socialismo ha señalado que
los legisladores estarían entre los
primeros a ser vacunados lo que ha
generado una ola de críticas de hecho el
presidente luís arte que debería ser
vacunado en la en el inicio de la
campaña ha desistido de esta idea y lo
va a hacer en los próximos días
mary dejando de lado el tema de las
vacunas cómo está la situación en
general en bolivia le pregunto porque
semanas atrás veíamos escasez de oxígeno
en algunas ciudades
vimos saturación en el sistema de salud
en la paz y en la ciudad del alto
también
la situación estaba empezando a salirse
de control para las autoridades cómo
está ahora
bolivia está sufriendo una situación
crítica por el embate de la segunda ola
de coronavirus los médicos aseguran que
está segunda hora hola es mucho más
virulenta que la primera y está
provocando muchos más contagios de hecho
los casos de kobe 19 diarios están
aproximándose a los 3000 y se supera el
promedio que había ocurrido que se había
registrado en la primera ola
precisamente por eso los médicos que han
perdido a varios de sus colegas en esta
lucha han salido a protestar y han
pedido al gobierno de luis arce que
declaren la cuarentena rígida para
frenar la ola de contagios el gobierno
ha dicho que no va a declarar cuarentena
se niega a hacerlo porque considera que
es momento de recuperar la economía del
país es más
luisa se ha pedido a la población
boliviana a aguantar y resistir hasta
que llegue la vacuna para todos para que
se pueda dar una solución estructural al
coronavirus en su segunda ola en bolivia
esto obviamente le ha generado una serie
de críticas también de sus ojos
después consideran que el país no está
para aguantar pues la situación
sanitaria es alarmante y muchas gracias
por este reporte desde la ciudad de la
paz y ya si conocemos entonces cómo va a
comenzar a avanzar el plan de vacunación
en ese país suramericano mientras tanto
en uruguay el gobierno de este país
anunció que cerró un acuerdo para la
compra de vacunas desarrolladas por la
farmacéutica pfizer y también con la
compañía si novak el anuncio lo hizo el
presidente uruguayo luis lacalle pou
quien no especificó la cantidad de dosis
tampoco dijo cuándo comenzaría a hacer
plan de inoculación a nivel nacional el
mandatario indicó que avanza también en
la negociación con otras compañías
farmacéuticas para adquirir más dosis
uruguay y paraguay eran los únicos
países de suramérica que no habían
anunciado compra de vacunas a ninguno de
los laboratorios que ya tienen aprobadas
algunas de ellas uruguay registra hasta
el momento más de 39 mil 800 casos y
cerca de 415 personas han fallecido en
ese país suramericano
y esta semana también el presidente
mexicano andrés manuel lópez obrador fue
diagnosticado con kobe 19 una noticia
que le dio la vuelta al mundo uno de los
mandatarios más escépticos frente a la
crisis de la pandemia el mandatario de
los mexicanos indicó que está recibiendo
tratamientos médicos y que se retiraría
de algunas de sus labores oficiales esto
mientras méxico avanza en su plan de
vacunación pero los nuevos casos de
contagio no dan tregua
el presidente del país andrés manuel
lópez obrador dio positivo por
coronavirus el mandatario ha sido
fuertemente criticado por la gestión que
ha hecho de la pandemia de coronavirus
en el país desde el inicio de la
emergencia minimizó su impacto siento
que no vamos a atender problemas mayores
y mientras otros países de la región
imponían restricciones su administración
se resistía no dejen
salir todavía estamos en la primera fase
ya nosotros yo les voy a decir cuando no
salga a pesar de haber sufrido un
infarto y padecer hipertensión rara vez
se le ha visto con la mascarilla en
público a lo largo de la pandemia ha
continuado sus viajes y mítines por
diferentes puntos del país y ha seguido
saludando a sus simpatizantes con
apretones de manos y abrazos por el
coronavirus eso sí que éste no se puede
uno abrazar
hay que abrazarse si no pasa nada o sea
éste
y
así promovió dudosos métodos para una
supuesta protección ante el contagio de
este ente
detente
ahora hablo se une a otros líderes
mundiales que han contraído la
enfermedad como el ex presidente
estadounidense donald trump el
presidente brasileño jair bolsonaro o el
primer ministro británico boris johnson
también ellos restaron importancia al
impacto del virus y se negaron al inicio
de la pandemia a imponer restricciones
el primer caso de la enfermedad se
detectó a finales de febrero en ese país
menos de un año después ya suma 150.000
muertes por corona virus méxico es la
cuarta nación a nivel mundial con mayor
número de muertes por esa enfermedad
vamos a ampliar la información de lo que
está sucediendo en méxico mario'
carbonell en la capital mexicana nos
dará más información y más detalles
mario comencemos por la salud del
presidente de lópez obrador que se sabe
de su condición y cómo está avanzando
con su enfermedad
de acuerdo con los más recientes
reportes tanto del subsecretario de
salud hugo lópez gatell como de la
secretaria de gobernacion olga sánchez
cordero que son los encargados de dar a
conocer el estado de salud del
presidente refieren que ha evolucionado
de manera muy favorable que se encuentra
tranquilo que está contento de buen
ánimo y con muchos deseos de
reincorporarse a sus actividades
cotidianas esto después de una serie de
versiones especulativas en el sentido de
que la salud del presidente se habría
agravado y también tras la visita este
jueves a palacio nacional del sacerdote
alejandro solalinde un personaje muy
cercano al presidente no obstante las
autoridades han salido a frenar estos
rumores a dejar en claro que andrés
manuel lópez obrador va presentando
mejoría que está de buen ánimo y que se
encuentra pues ya nada más esperando a
que terminen estos días de confinamiento
para volver a las actividades
mario también fue noticia esta semana
que méxico compró un lote de 24 millones
de dosis de la vacuna rusa sputnik para
complementar las otras dosis de vacuna
que ya está inoculando allí a sus
habitantes cómo está avanzando el plan
de vacunación como han sido recibido
este avance de la inoculación a nivel
nacional méxico va liderando en el
ranking a nivel latinoamericano
pues ha habido una polémica después de
este anuncio del acuerdo de compra de 24
millones de dosis de la vacuna de
sputnik en el sentido de que aún no se
conocen los resultados de la fase 3 de
ensayos clínicos e incluso algunos
legisladores del partido del presidente
como germán martínez han cuestionado
pues que se de este trato el país que se
compre este tipo de vacunas aún no
aprobadas sin embargo autoridades como
por ejemplo el secretario de hacienda
arturo herrera que fue el encargado de
pues a autorizar esta compra que por
cierto no se concreta finalmente ha
dicho arturo herrera que méxico no
compra vacunas de segunda que la
efectividad de las vacunas con las que
se tiene acuerdo de compra es superior
al 94 por ciento y por ejemplo también
el canciller marcelo ebrard salió a
decir que se conoce la efectividad de
las gracias a los expedientes a los que
se tuvo acceso de la aplicación en
argentina de modo que pues estamos en
espera de estas dosis como también
estamos en espera de que se reanuden los
envíos
la cuna de facer que como sabemos fueron
suspendidos pero se reanudarán el
próximo 15 de febrero hasta el momento
de esta vacuna de facer que es la única
que tenemos en el país se han aplicado
650 mil dosis y hubo una polémica porque
se comenzó a vacunar a maestros del
estado de campeche con el fin de
eventualmente volver a clases
presenciales sin embargo pues los
médicos de santidad han cuestionado que
aún no se termina de inocular al
personal de la salud y que ellos son los
que deberían estar primeros en la lista
maría vale la pena recordar las medidas
y las restricciones que tiene méxico
todavía vigentes porque a pesar de que
el plan de inmunización está avanzando
la cantidad de casos de personas
contagiadas sigue siendo muy alto y ni
que decir de la cifra de personas que
han fallecido sobre todo en ciudad de
méxico
así es en la ciudad es méxico las
autoridades han anunciado que se seguirá
en semáforo rojo toda vez que en esta
semana pues hubo nuevo récord de muertes
reportadas en un solo día con 460 de
hecho fueron dos días que se acumularon
de récord de muertes hay aún más de
7.200 personas hospitalizadas y es por
ello que hasta el 8 de febrero se podrán
reabrir los centros comerciales por
ejemplo continúan las restricciones del
semáforo rojo y no solamente la capital
del país otros 13 estados son 14
entidades en total las que se encuentran
en semáforo rojo una situación no vista
desde agosto pasado y pues el hecho de
que méxico haya superado las 155 mil
muertes que lo colocan ya en tercer
lugar superando a india pues tienen al
país aún con el pico de la pandemia y
las restricciones en efecto
graciasmaria por este reporte desde
ciudad de méxico un completo reporte de
la situación allí esta semana también
colombia superó la barra
de los 2 millones de personas
contagiadas más de 52 mil personas han
fallecido en este país suramericano
entre ellas el ministro de defensa que
estaba en el cargo carlos holmes
trujillo quien fue diagnosticado con
kobe 19 y por varios días estuvo en una
sala de cuidado intensivo el gobierno
del presidente iván duque anunció que la
vacunación a nivel nacional comenzará a
partir del 20 de febrero una fecha
aproximada no podemos olvidar también la
variante brasileña que tiene presencia
en el país fronterizo colombia-brasil
tienen una extensa frontera en la zona
del amazonas vamos a valorar la
situación en colombia y para ello vamos
a conectar entonces con luís muñoz
periodista de france 24 en bogotá la
capital colombiana
lluís cuál es la situación entonces de
las vacunas en colombia cuántas dosis
han comprado cuando se espera que
lleguen allí ya dicen que el plan va a
comenzar a partir del 20 de febrero pero
cuando llegaran al país
así es santiago la situación en colombia
es de inquietud
los colombianos ven como sus países
vecinos están iniciando la vacunación
mientras que en el país no parece que
vayan a empezar las vacunaciones hasta
el 20 de febrero cuando llegaran las
primeras dosis a colombia el país ya ha
comprado cerca de 50 millones de vacunas
10 millones de facer 10 millones de
astrazéneca 20 millones de la plataforma
kóvacs y 9 millones de janssen cabe
destacar que todo indica que va a ser un
proceso lento el medio estadounidense
the economist situó finales de 2022 como
fecha para que termine la vacunación
masiva en colombia yo ya lo decía yo la
introducción en este país suramericano
el virus está avanzando muy rápido ya
hay más de 2 millones de personas
contagiadas y más de 52.000 de han
perdido la vida entre ellas el ministro
de defensa lo mencionaba carlos holmes
trujillo cómo cayó esta noticia en la
sociedad colombiana en el gobierno en la
situación que se está viviendo como dice
usted hay mucha incertidumbre por lo que
está pasando allí
el martes será un día difícil de olvidar
para los colombianos para el presidente
iván duque muertes como la de holmes
trujillo arruga en el corazón tanto es
así que se decretaron tres días de luto
nacional además de brindarle un funeral
con honores la comunidad política
internacional lamentaron el
fallecimiento y en las calles de bogotá
se vieron banderas a media asta así como
homenajes de militares y policías a los
que lideraba falleció a los 69 años y
era uno de los hombres fuertes del
centro democrático partido del
expresidente álvaro uribe vélez ese
mismo martes también es importante
resaltar la muerte de julio gómez un
importante líder sindical presidente de
la confederación general de trabajo que
tampoco pudo superar la enfermedad
respiratoria causada por el kobe 19 y
también hay temor en colombia por esa
variante procedente de brasil estos dos
países colombia y brasil tienen una
extensa frontera en la zona del amazonas
e incluso tienen ciudades binacionales
ciudades en todo el punto fronterizo
como la capital del departamento amazona
en la ciudad de leticia qué medidas ha
tomado el gobierno colombiano cómo están
manejando la situación allí porque
recordemos que al principio de la
pandemia
leticia fue uno de los puntos
neurálgicos de la llegada del virus y
hubo muchísimos casos allí incluso la
ciudad estuvo aislada durante unas
semanas
efectivamente santiago este jueves
colombia anunció que suspendía todas sus
conexiones aéreas con brasil al menos
durante 30 días esto es debido a la
variante brasileña que podría ser más
contagiosa y tener una posible evasión
de respuesta inmune del cuerpo las
autoridades de salud estudiarán cuáles
son los efectos en los próximos 30 días
además bogotá ha suspendido a las
conexiones con la ciudad de leticia
ubicada en el departamento del amazonas
ante el riesgo de que la variante
pudiese descontrolarse por el país al
ser una región fronteriza con brasil el
20 de diciembre y colombia ya había
suspendido vuelos con reino unido por la
variante británica que dicen que es un
70 por ciento más contagiosa por otro
lado en bogotá la capital colombiana se
ha visto un descenso de la ocupación de
las unidades de cuidados intensivos al
88 por ciento tras haber llegado en las
pasadas semanas al 94% y esto de una
motivada que la alcaldía levante el
confinamiento total de fin de semana que
ha estado rigiendo hasta ahora aunque
mantendrá el toque de queda entre las 10
de la noche y las 4 de la mañana
lluís muchas gracias por este reporte
desde bogotá la capital de colombia
desde ahí nos vamos hasta perú el
gobierno
interino francisco sagasti anunció
recientemente nuevas restricciones y
cuarentenas para el área metropolitana
de la ciudad de lima el puerto del
callao y también para nueve regiones de
ese país una medida que se extenderá
hasta el próximo 14 de febrero pero un
amplio sector de la sociedad se opone a
estas medidas que aseguran está
perjudicando gravemente la ya compleja y
afectada economía peruana
en medio de un rápido aumento de nuevas
infecciones cientos de peruanos se
tomaron las calles de lima este jueves
para protestar contra las nuevas medidas
restrictivas anunciadas por el gobierno
el presidente interino francisco sagasti
anunció el martes el cierre total de la
capital y de otras 9 regiones a partir
del próximo lunes para evitar un
desborde del sistema sanitario medidas
rechazadas por un amplio sector de la
ciudadanía que teme un impacto demasiado
profundo para la economía no enviaremos
a otros denuncian una conspiración
internacional para afectar al país
el gobierno proveniente a directivas
internacionales que se imponen a nivel
mundial es de suprimir la libertad
en los propósitos que tienen estás
cuarentenas es quebrar la economía no
solamente de este país sino de todos los
países para hacer un reseteo mundial
pero con más de 40 mil muertes es uno de
los países más golpeados de la región y
ahora hace frente a una nueva oleada de
contagios que tiene a los sistemas
hospitalarios al límite pero el límite
está también la economía que cayó un
11.6 por ciento en 2020 y se inspira que
la vacunación no empiece hasta febrero y
en nuestra sección en redes veamos otras
noticias destacadas de la semana aquí en
kobe 19 la semana en américa veamos este
anuncio de la compañía de biotecnología
estadounidense novavax que anunció que
su vacuna contra el kobe 19 ha
demostrado una eficacia del 89 punto 3%
en su ensayo de fase 3 realizado en el
reino unido- esta vacuna está basada en
proteínas y también demostró ser muy
eficaz contra la variante británica
aunque ha demostrado que es menos
efectiva contra la variante sudafricana
es todo por el momento aquí en kobe 19
la semana en américa nos vemos la
próxima semana siga con nosotros
[Música]